[Music]
hello and welcome back to steampunks
gamespot pc focus show where we talk
about things that affect PC users and
gamers in general but mostly have a
focus on PC
I'm image analyst McDonald and this week
we're going to talk about micro
transactions why why are we talking
about micro transactions yes so we want
to talk about what is the problem with
micro transactions and the reason we're
talking about this with that this week
is because of the law that was passed in
Belgium saying that micro transactions
are gambling it's a game of chance we're
sipping blue box isn't it it's typically
loot boxes so you're putting money into
loot boxes where you don't know exactly
what you're getting out that constitutes
is gambling they've said as a law that
you will be subject to be taken to court
if people like EA Activision Blizzard
keep those things in their games the
really interesting thing with Belgium is
everybody has pulled out of having loot
boxes in their game so I'm over what she
could no longer buy loot boxes from
watch in Belgium yeah Activision
Blizzard's on board everybody got on
board except for EA EA are refusing to
take loot boxes out of paper they're
actually willing to go to court over it
and when you hear the ridiculous
statistic that 67% of EA's revenue from
last year was because all the loot boxes
because of my tricked microtransactions
it makes sense it's an interesting
gaming world we're living in where
that's the truth that's strange because
I figure that Blizzard you know would
make a similar amount of money from
overwatch leave boxes yeah the thing
with difference between Blizzard in the
EA is that Blizzard as far as I know
like it's only types of cosmetics like I
have a watch like costumes and emotes
and all that kind of stuff that EA there
is a little bit of progression that
obviously there's a huge battlefront
drama about the loot boxes being tied to
your skills and abilities in your game
and you know obviously in the sports
games the Ultimate Team is a very
popular mode getting ahead in that game
it can come from finally boxes and
getting a lucky lucky draw really we do
see similar numbers from Activision
Blizzard they made 2 billion dollars
that's a lot of us that's a lot of
dollars so that's actually the same
amount so what they made out of
microtransactions no loot boxes
specifically was 4 billion dollars 2
billion of that came from
the mobile games so they own candy crush
now and on that entire conglomerate of
games that was 2 billion the other half
though was from the PC console
microtransaction market but yeah I can
see why EA did try what they tried with
battlefront because the entire point of
these loot boxes and microtransactions
is giving people incentive to want to
buy them in the first place yes and I
think keying onto that incentive part
while not coming off consumer unfriendly
is the balancing act with
microtransactions yeah so I think what
they were hoping with battlefront is
what we've got if we give people skilled
cards that make them better at the game
that's an incentive more incentive but
what they came up as as was Jax I think
there are interesting ways to approach
incentive that people like epic are
doing with fortnight when they have
limited time Cosmetics
yeah so you can buy like a cool skin a
cool outfit and then it'll only be
around for 24 hours you either buy it or
you don't and it doesn't come up again
there's also that thing is actually
making those cosmetics look really cool
like if you love fortnight if you love
overwatch and you have a favorite
character you want to buy the stuff that
makes something look really cool and be
proud of them and be proud of showing
that in a match
everybody hates loot boxes weird books
like not the thing that people are fans
of but you look at these numbers people
are buying them yeah I you know I would
readily admit to buying too many
overwatch loot boxes and it is like it's
it's so annoying as a concept at the
same time there is a innate satisfaction
opening that loop box watching that
animation and if you get something that
you really really want something that's
really rare you know you feel that feels
really good that's not interesting to me
because I've never bought a loop but
really I never would I can't imagine
being in that seis Y so desperately won
a cosmetic or oral if I said I felt like
I needed to put extra money in to get a
leg up in a multiplayer competition in
in something like battlefront I think
that would put me off the game yeah yeah
I level put me off the game as well the
reason why I buy loot boxes for certain
games or I put money into micro
transactions per second game is because
I play a lot of those games like sure I
paid 60 bucks but ever watch to begin
with and I put like you know 400 500
hours of that game
put 700 hours said into dota 2 you know
and so I'm happy and dota 2 is a free
game and I've put so much my life into
it that I'm happy to throw valve yeah a
few dollars here and there the thing
that really gets me is that we we can
play about microtransactions all the
time you know I complain about them
everyone complains about them but
everyone buys them it's crazy
using the dota 2 example specifically
obviously they had their big annual
international forum at the International
2018 this year they each the prideful
for that every year starts off at one
point six million dollars like that's
nothing
and the prize pool grows based on the
sales of the compendium battle path
which valve sells every year it comes
with like exclusive skins emotes you
know map skins a nice fantasy league a
bracket thing it's ten bucks there's a
small portion of that that go to the
final prize pool for the tournament you
know that's really nice because you're
giving back to the players as well and
you know it's only ten bucks out of your
pocket but think about that the prize
pool this year was the biggest it's ever
been it's twenty five and a half million
dollars yeah on top of the initial 1.6
million that's a lot it's a lot and
considering that only a small portion of
those that cost went to the actual price
ball valid must be making so much money
and I think it's also great companies
like that turning those profits into
experiences that we want like not just
being like I have a giant pile of money
now but taking that money and turning it
into other games that we want to play
other experiences that we get to have
from that develop oh yeah well making
the those existing games better look at
a shinier like but given this billion
dollar amounts that's a really good
chance that a bunch of you guys watching
have engaged in microtransactions where
the loot boxes or otherwise at some
point so let us know if you have why you
have and if you feel like in general
microtransactions are a good or a bad
thing yeah what kind of
microtransactions yeah nothing to buy
and while we're asking you for your
comments on this week's topic thank you
very much for your comments on last
week's topic where we talked about what
platform you should play certain
multi-platform games on is the PC is it
not PC here's what you had to say Jedi
KB on site I said I tried to stick to PC
where possible why and listed a bunch of
points including a better refund policy
higher frame rates making the games more
responsive and PC games being able to
travel between machines which is more
difficult between console generations
without keeping the old hardware that
said they said they wouldn't go for PC
if the port was bad buggy or an
afterthought if they needed a
split-screen or local multiplayer which
is something we mentioned last week and
another thing we mentioned is a when
your friends pull you out of being on PC
and you get stuck on console when you
didn't really want to be there yeah all
valid points PC gamers have often been
burned on bad ports Arkham Knight for
example in GTA 4 which involving pretty
bad yeah so you know if you don't have
another avenue to play those games it
can be really tough and you yelling at
all baseman on GameSpot said PC is
always best best graphics best
performance massive keyboard decibel
couch mods etc is so versatile and none
of the limitations of consoles I only
play exclusives on consoles because I
can't play the PC that's you know
basically the general sentiment of a lot
of people yeah
PC graphics are always gonna be better
than any console I find myself every
time I play a PC game I get really
obsessed over the graphics I'm like
twiddling the menus making sure my frame
it is that optimal 60 frames per second
all the time making sure that I'm
getting the highest resolution like
making sure it's like like downsample if
I'm more than 1080 monitor yeah making
sure the 4k is working fine I get
obsessed with that stuff you had the
frame counter in the bottom corner
making sure it never goes below 60 that
stuff I don't worry about on console
because I know I can't affect it yeah so
that's something that I like to avoid
sometimes by just 1/8 so yeah and enjoy
a game without any hassles we also got a
comment from Kaos blades on YouTube
saying their preference was PC because
in 20 years I can have a new PC and
still play it without some proprietary
hardware today I can still load up my
original copy of games from 1995 on the
same system I'm going to play shadow of
the Tomb Raider on I totally relate to
this because I love going back and
playing like my old favorites from from
like the late 90s or 2000s and having as
we've talked about in a previous episode
having sites like GOG good that support
those and still make really old games
work and just being able to have the
same system running the coolest new game
out there that runs like a dream it has
the most amazing graph that you've ever
seen
something from 95 is really cool yeah
the compatibility can sometimes be an
issue but most of the time like PC games
age would do leave us your micro
transaction related opinions and
comments down in that section below and
let us know what you want us to talk
about on the show next week we will see
you then yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]